it's not easy to take in the blood on
the clothes
the stained altar
and the remains
all inside nayamata church prince
charles told how ten thousand tootsie
and their supporters were mascot here
the new coffins are for more victims
only recently found
outside the prince was shown a grave
that already holds 45 000 bodies
some of the killers who are in prison
some of them they confess where they're
heading their bodies when they refund
them we collect them we brought them
here just to prepare the decent burial
at the genocide memorial in kigali they
heard how in just a hundred days in 1994
up to a million were killed when the
hutu government declared the tutsis as
enemies of the state
250 000 are buried here in mass graves
but the prince wanted to go further than
other dignitaries getting out of the
capital to visit a reconciliation
village where perpetrators and survivors
live side by side
and now we do a situation
as
the prince has really wanted to draw
attention to the amazing ways in which
they've managed to move on here and all
the horrific stories that he's been told
mean that there is very little risk that
we can ignore reporting on it it's been
so shocking and of course that ties in
with the fact that in the coming days he
knows there is likely to be more
attention on other things he's spoken
about recently most importantly
britain's immigration policy and sending
people here to rwanda it's understood
the prince privately said he was
appalled by the new policy to fly
migrants here genocide survivor and
former international footballer eric
maragwa has been advising the prince
ahead the trip and told me the
immigration issue is a disappointing
distraction the majority of rwandans
including those in position in power
have lived the life of refugees so they
very genuinely understand
why you know
trying to work with the uk to solve this
problem
there was a welcome smile even if
president kagame may not be impressed
with his apparent thoughts on the
immigration deal and for the prince
another potentially awkward conversation
lies ahead a cup of tea with boris
johnson on friday morning as he also
flies in for the meeting of commonwealth
heads rhiannon mills sky news in kigali